new in theaters this week mile 22 alpha
and crazy rich Asians what will you see
this is your weekend ticket you want to
see a movie this weekend heck you better
they better be mild 22 mark Whalberg
mile 22 leeet's theaters this weekend as
hard as Wahlberg's co-star Eco waste
hits this guy in the face
this gritty in your face action thriller
takes you along for a ride with a small
paramilitary team as they attempt to
transport a very very important
intelligence asset from the American
Embassy to an extraction point 22 miles
away oh I get it mile 22 with Peter Berg
directing and an ass-kicking cast
including Ronda Rousey and John
Malkovich mile 22 is sure to deliver on
the punching and the kicking this movies
for you if you like
EKOS other violent action movies like
the raid redemption or the raid 2 or
you've heard the rumors that Marky Mark
threw in the hip-hop towel to pursue
acting and you won't believe it until
you see it with your own eyes surprising
right also in theaters this weekend
alpha alpha is the origin story of the
first-ever Instagram dog alpha is the
origin story of the first ever bond
between man and dog sad 20,000 years ago
a young injured hunter saves a similarly
injured wolf and they become like best
buds the boy gives the wolf some water
and the wolf helps the boy find his
family and become a man seems like a
fair trade with stunning visuals and an
adventurous yet equally adorable plot
this movie is for you if you like
coming-of-age stories you're moved by
visually powerful movies like 300 or
Life of Pi or you love dogs can't afford
this so your family is rich we're
comfortable that is exactly what a super
rich person would say
and finally crazy rich Asians is in
theaters this weekend currently sitting
with
ninety-seven percent on the Rotten
Tomatoes tomato meter this Asian
American led rom-com is generating a lot
of buzz as a beacon for Asian
representation in Hollywood with
Constance Wu and Henry Golding as the
leads the story follows chinese-american
economics professor Rachel Chu as she
heads to Singapore with her boyfriend
for a wedding while there she meets the
family and uh guess what they're crazy
rich no no there's a few fingers this
movie is for you if you like comedies
that are crazy romantic or romances that
are crazy comedic you've ever had to
deal with a crazy judgmental in-law or
prove your worthiness to your
significant others family or if you've
ever fantasized about buying a seemingly
normal painting from a garage sale only
to get home and realize that there's a
super valuable yet priceless Picasso
hiding behind it
crazy right that is your weekend ticket
what will you see and check back next
week for a futuristic robot dog
yay more dog movies
[Music]
you